Trí phụ của con nội thái lan cho biết vào sáng nửa sọ thăm một, đã xảy ra sự có khán quảng ngoại imo nửa
việc cắm của chia thường về khu vực gáo điểm bộn sảo chiến luôn bình phòng trong bóc tình ubong rắt chào thán
ý kênh một biến sĩ thái lan bị thương theo thông tin từ quân khu hai của thái lan, sự việc diễn ra vào lúc quảng
mấy giờ hai mâm lắm cũng tại vì chỉ lực lợp đặc nhiệm suradnary đang làm nhiều vụ.
Thì em công tác điều tra đăng được tiền hàng và sâm mình loại vụ khi đến quan.
Nông thời các đơn vị được yêu cầu tăng cường mà đặc an in và kính giác.
Ngay sau đó bộ trường ngoại sáo thái lan, xí sắc sặc khu ăn kết cao đã ăn giữ công thàn tới công phù chia.
Nên gỳ có lợi dải thích chính thức mời lệm vận hiện bất cảnh được vui chỉ hơi sự thần trọng cao độ từ cả hay bên.
Fía công phù chia đã lợi dải thích bàn đầu, khẳng ring đây là sự cộng ngoại imo nửa tụi lắm thời thái lan, ăn nửa tin cho vì được quân cho biết,
đã nhận được bảo cảo cơm nhật và nhìn mạnh.
Thái lan mong muốn cấp của chia có dải chính thức quả cân ngoại dau.
Ông còn định, Thái lan chưa có quả quý tắc dạo chiến và chưa thành động đắt trả,
sau mừng được quân đội bệnh vui chỉ trọng thải sản sản trên đấu.